you know there are times in your life
when you just want to try something
different
something new but when you reach 90
years old maybe those passions fade a
little but not for jerry eisenberg
he's written countless sports stories
for the star ledger in new jersey
he's lived in las vegas now for the last
decade and still writes stories he's
written over a dozen books
eisenberg has attended every super bowl
except for the last few
and not because of a lack of desire his
legs are letting him down just a little
bit
but at 90 he's able to cross one thing
off his bucket
list and that's a novel and here's a
peek
sports writer jerry eisenberg has been
pounding keys for over a half a century
he's written thousands of sports columns
for the star ledger in new jersey
he's still only semi-retired he's
written 13 books a biography
and now for the first time at age 90 a
novel
i had never written a novel that was the
top of my bucket list
to write that novel and i started it
when i
turned 88 and
it was something i i remember a high
school teacher i had
once said to me you know you could be a
writer what would you like to
write about and i said well you know my
father was a professional ball player
i think i'd like to be a sports writer
and he looked at me like he was scraping
door crap off the bottom of his shoe
right and said well if you ever get
serious about writing
make sure you write what you know or
when it came to the novel i said to
myself what do i know
what do i read all these other books and
all these columns
i knew of that because i lived it but to
write a novel what do i know
well the first thing i knew was the city
of newark
which i grew up in i loved
i lived there in newark or
just outside of newark until i came out
here 12 years ago
that was number one number two was the
riot which i was very familiar with the
causes
it was the newark riots in 1967 that
sets the stage for jerry's novel
the perfect backdrop for what would
eventually lead to the unlikely
and lasting romance in newark new jersey
an unfounded rumor that a man had died
in police custody
triggered five nights of gunfire arson
and looting
that left 26 people dead and
neighborhoods in ruins
after the riot most of the jews and the
irish and the
germans and the polar poles
they moved out of the city it was
because we expected another riot
and i i was stunned that we didn't have
one
so that was another thing i knew and i
said
how am i gonna oh and i knew the mafia
because i'd been in the headquarters in
newark i've been in
i knew all those guys said and they got
i got to make a phony election and i'll
bring these guys in to fix it
because they're capable of it right and
then
it all came down to what's going to hold
it all together
black white love affair during
the days of starting five months after
the riot
and both are college kids
some of the stories in the book are
loosely related to eisenberg's own life
like his own interracial marriage to his
wife of 42 years
it was nothing like the two fictional
characters in this book had to do
because hatred was everywhere and the
name of the book
you know is after the fire
love and hate in the ashes of 1967.
the two main characters in the book meet
as teenagers
a black woman and a white man they meet
in the most unusual of all circumstances
i don't want to give away too much but
i'll tell you they they go to high
school together these kids they don't
speak
there's 1400 kids whose names end in a
vowel
they're italian at barrington high
school
now they change the rules and they're
going to let anybody go there
if it's not too crowded so 40 blacks
don't show up in a group but they go
there
well the way they solve the problem is
the blacks don't acknowledge the
italians
the italians don't acknowledge the
blacks so
they go to school together these two
kids they pass each other into a horse
20 times a day
they stand in the cafeteria that not one
word in four years is spoken between
them
five months after the riot he gets a job
because the italians are still
controlling the political jump
in the post office short email for this
summer
the postal authorities want to bring
more blacks so she gets a summer job
they wind up shorting mail next to each
other
she's mad she's mad not at him she's mad
at the high school days and the behavior
i mean she's just mad
so she is throwing the mail into the
little pigeon boom boom boom
and he's looking at he says you know i
think i know you miss
and she says you don't know me and she
don't show you
boom boom boom in four years advantage
you didn't want to know me
and i didn't want to know you and i
don't want to know you
now you don't know me you recognize me
and if you really want to do me a favor
you want anyone do me a favor
stop talking don't say another word the
next words out of your mouth are going
to be
some of your best friends are black and
then she gets back to sir
and now a guy who's got a political job
coming by and he gets
it's the first day of work for both of
them he maneuvers him into a corner dark
corner
and he's groping here well i use what my
father told me going
every ethnic we were jewish i still am
every ethnic group in a city they would
tell their kids the same boys
if you see a girl in trouble it's your
problem and with your sister
break his neck so i transposed that to
his italian father
thing he's off the shore left hooks the
guy to the shoulder the guy vomits force
that
they walk back to the they don't say a
word they walk back to the store
she's saying geez i picked the fight
with this guy look what he did for me
i got to apologize she gets off the show
in a very different pose
and says to him i think i owe you an
apology
he looks him he says you don't owe me
crap and i don't owe you crap for 40
years or whatever it was
i'm not apologizing with her i don't
want your applause i don't need money
in fact you want to do me a favor shut
up just don't say another word because
the next word out of your mouth would be
some of your best friends are white and
then they look at each other
and they realize how ridiculous and they
laugh and that's how their love affair
starts
this is a story of despair
and hate and optimism
and in the end i'm not going to give
away the ending but in the end
it's a story of hope and uh it's funny
because
i will tell you one thing everybody will
say my wife is a woman in a book victory
but she's some some of the things are
but not many of them
but one thing definitely is
we were falling in love and
our first date we went on the staten
island ferry i went to
went to little italy had dinner down to
staten island ferry to head back toward
new jersey
there's a full moon on the water i'm
looking at her
she's looking at me and suddenly we're
saying to ourselves
you know this could be love that's how
the two hero
the hero and the heroine that's how they
found they're in love in the book too
but i would like to tell you one addict
thoughts by the way remember this book
is totally new jersey
new jersey new jersey and speak another
language
they've had some trouble editing my book
when the guy says i
didn't d-i-n-t do that and i want to ask
you a question
one time well you know i had to explain
it's written in jersey anna so i
apologize to the others but this
this book was going to be the way we
spoke and the way the city was
all of the restaurants in the city are
in the book all the fast food places are
in the book
my agent did not want to represent this
book
he said you're writing about people in a
different era nobody under 60 will buy
the book
and you don't realize that those times
have passed you know
and i said listen don't tell me about
times being pissed
nobody writes a biography of lincoln
today nobody writes about napoleon
nobody nobody writes about fdr no i
think it's relevant
he said look i think it's well done but
i don't think i'm going to represent
it's too much effort for too little
return okay
after he gets a copy of the book he
calls me up and he says
i think i made a mistake with you well
it wasn't a mistake for me because i
structured my own deal and i didn't have
any 15
to pay any agent to do it okay but
he said you know i was right when i told
you the times were gone but the times
in america came back to you and black
lives matter
this book is the most relevant book i've
seen i said okay
represented for a movie he said i'll do
that
all right thank you very much jerry
appreciate that you can find jerry's new
novel at into your favorite outlet sir
hey